who makes the best 15 inch laptop we
have Dell's new XPS 15 right here and
Apple's M2 15-inch MacBook Air now here
are the specs and you see the Dell is
2850 bucks compared to 1700 so no
MacBooks are not that expensive but we
will see if that money is worth it
because we're comparing everything from
the design to Ports the displays
speakers and of course the performance
let's start out with the external design
and the Dell looks very similar to what
they've been doing for a while I'm gonna
stack it on the MacBook right over here
if you guys can see that it is actually
smaller than the 15 inch air but if we
compare the thickness the MacBook is
basically the same thickness as just the
bottom part of the XPS and if I hold
them so side by side like this the
MacBook is so much lighter we have 3.3
pounds compared to 4.4 but of course
Dell is packing a lot in here including
a 88 watt hour battery compared to 66.
now we'll talk about battery life in
just a bit but of course the XPS also
has fans built in for that powerful
processor and graphics compared to the
completely fanless MacBook now as far as
ports I love that we have the macsafe
connector on the MacBook it will connect
here very convenient with Adele you just
have USBC for charging but they give you
this crazy big
130 watt power adapter and that should
say something about the performance
built in now both have two USB C's on
the side they are both Thunderbolt and
on the other side we have headphone
Jacks but the XPS also comes with
another USB type-c ports and an SD card
reader Apple why could you not build one
into this I mean maybe because it's so
thin I don't know now on the inside I
love that the Dell has Windows hello so
I can just automatically log you in of
course both of these have fingerprint
scanners for security and as far as the
keyboards I've been using this XPS and I
have to say that I prefer its keyboard
over the MacBook airs it just has a
little bit more travel but as far as
track pads the XPS cannot compete with
the macbook's magnetic trackpad it feels
much better than the standard diving
board design now the new Air has a six
speaker system built into it which is
pretty impressive whereas the XPS has a
quad speaker system so let's go ahead
and compare them
[Music]
thank you
wow guys you heard that difference for
yourself I am impressed this thing
sounds so good better than XPS 17s did
in the past so Dell listened not only is
it much louder a lot louder I thought
it's gonna peek it it sounds good
overall I would definitely take the XPS
speakers now as far as webcams the
MacBook Air has a 1080p webcam built in
while the Dell still has a 720p webcam
let me know which one looks better and
which one sounds better down in the
comments now as far as the displays we
have a lot of differences both of them
are 16 by 10 and the Dell has these
super slim bezels on the side is slimmer
than the slim ones on the air already
but the resolution on this Dell is
really high it's 3.5 K compared to 2.8
not only that but it is also an OLED
compared to regular LCD now as far as
brightness the the OLED hits 400 nits
compared to 500 on the LCD so it's a
little bit less bright but it has really
good anti-reflectivity Coatings to help
with bright environments now the huge
positive is the contrast levels because
it is a OLED display and looking at this
HDR footage the Dell looks really really
good I mean it looks incomparably bright
while having great contrast and then
when the lights are off the LCD screen
on the MacBook is just really great you
don't have that Peak brightness the Dell
looks incredible as far as detail it
looks really good as well the brights
just really pop and then with that
speaker system I mean this is going to
be a killer movie watching experience
and now let's get into performance I'm
going to start out with an SSD speed
test we have one terabyte compared to
512 now this one is the upgraded one so
you have your your full performance and
one interesting thing is with the Dell
you can actually go up to eight
terabytes compared to maxing out with
two on the MacBook Air and look at that
oh my goodness we just got the read
speed in here
7137 compared to
3466 more than what more than twice the
speed that's insane and for the right
speed 6300 compared to 3400 close to
double the performance wow this is
actually faster than like a 16 inch
MacBook Pro impressive and now opening
up geekbench 6 here we see that we have
the i7
13700h this thing goes up to 4.8
gigahertz for the top and we have 14
cores compared to eight cores we also
have 32 gigs of RAM compared to 16 but I
know from previous testing 16 gives you
full performance and with the MacBook
you can only go up to 24 gigs maximum
but of course it is unit unified memory
so it's a little bit more efficient and
we have our scores here as far as single
chord the MacBook does Beat It Out 2600
compared to about 2500 but multi-core
the XPS is beating out the M2 Chip by
just a little bit as you guys notice
though the XPS is unplugged now I did
have it in high performance a mode in
the window settings and in the Dell
settings the extreme or Ultra
performance but let's go ahead and plug
it in and we'll see what we get and look
at that guys that is a nice bump we have
12 265 compared to
98.94 the MacBook performs the same
whether it's on battery or plugged in so
that's a difference of about 25
that also tells us if you want maximum
performance well you need to have it
plugged in now what about graphics
performance of course we have the M2
Chip this is the 10 core on Bend
compared to the RTX 4 40 70 built into
the XPS I'm going to go ahead and start
this Benchmark here now an interesting
thing with this Dell it's a 40 watt
version of that so it's a little bit
down clocked for this thin and
lightweight 15 inch design now the M2
Chip uses roughly half of that power
it's very efficient but let's see what
we get we have 45
607 metal score on the air and on the
XPS
397 for the opencl
that is what double a little bit more
than double very impressive and then
unplugged we have 82
000 so at that point it is a little bit
less than double but that's still very
impressive the drop was basically 10 000
going on to battery power so it's still
maintaining a lot of that performance
now what about gaming performance I have
3D Marks Wildlife extreme stream
unlimited here and it looks like we have
90.7 FPS compared to
41.3 more than double on the XPS plugged
in this thing is impressive and then
running it again on battery power we
have
68.1 now we constantly talk about
performance when it's on battery and in
this case yes that did drop quite a bit
but when it is still much more powerful
than a Macbook I'm not going to complain
about that because in the past it would
be much slower and it's a laptop you're
going to use it unplugged so I would say
when performance is good that is still
nice but what about some real world
productivity programs I have blender
opened up right here with the party tug
project and the speed difference is
insane the MacBook took 4 minutes 52
seconds compared to
58.9 seconds literally 5 times faster
the crazy thing is when I unplugged it
took a minute 13 and that's because of
the RTX graphics and the ray tracing
cores that enable it to be incredibly
fast and now I have Adobe Lightroom
opened up with 50 edited high resolution
images and shifting between these
looks like sometimes the XPS is faster
so far it's winning it most of the time
we have that great performance of course
that super fast SSD and now let's do an
AI test of course the MacBook Air has
that neural engine built in so this is
gonna try to find the background and
click it at the same time bam the
MacBook there was about twice as fast at
this task what about enhancing this
image let's open that up we'll run super
resolution which I love using
wow that was really close the MacBook
Beat It Out by about a second but pretty
close there and now let's export all 50
of these edited images I got rid of that
extra one and let's see what happens wow
the MacBook seems to be flying here and
it's the one that's on battery of course
with XPS if you unplug it you will lose
a bit of performance and just to make
sure I checked that the Dell is using
its Graphics quite a bit of it to help
bam the Dell just finish and look at
this guys we have two minutes 43 seconds
almost two minutes 44 compared to a
minute and
17. basically double the performance on
the MacBook that is crazy and that shows
off the benefits of the unified memory
architecture even when you have 16 gigs
now I have to point out that the MacBook
is fanless so if say you had 500 of
these tough images instead of 50 it
would start to throttle and slow down
but now that case it would still be
faster than this xbs and that is
impressive so for photo editing the
MacBook definitely takes the win now
what about your standard day-to-day
experience I have speedometer 2.0 opened
up right here and I'm running it it's
flashing fast on all of them this tests
your web browsing performance for
web-based applications like a lot of
people use and looking at the scores we
have 329 compared to
428 so the MacBook is definitely
snappier for web-based applications but
329 is still a good score and now I have
DaVinci Resolve 18.5 open for video
editing and here I have a 4K project
with color correction Luts applied film
grain and both these laptops are gonna
have no issues processing this one thing
that surprised me is how much of the
graphics performance is needed to do
this in real time we have about 32
percent compared to about 34 32 so the
RTX Graphics in this well your overhead
and the actual performance you have for
more effects they line up very similarly
and now let's go ahead and Export this
five minute project
um on the XPS I'm using nvidia's
encoders which are very fast and look at
that they were so close here but the XPS
beat out the MacBook a minute 22 seconds
compared to a minute
27. of course that is with it plugged in
and the fans going off I'm gonna try
this with the unplugged just to see what
it says and now it's giving us an
estimate of about two minutes 15 seconds
so it gets a lot slower on battery power
but I figure if you're going to be
rendering you'll probably find a plug-in
for that overall I have to give the
video editing win to the MacBook because
I was not expecting the performance to
be pretty much identical even though you
have half the graphics performance 16
gigs of RAM it's fanless and it's super
thin and of course you also have the
prores decoding and encoding uh chips
that are built in but the XPS has gotten
a lot faster compared to previous
generations and now let's talk about the
battery life our MacBook wasn't even 100
charged when we started and now it's
down to 50 after all of these tough
tests whereas the XPS even though we
only had brief amounts when we had
unplugged it's at 93 percent this thing
sucks power if you're doing tough things
like we were testing you're gonna get
two hours of battery life compared to
about six to eight on the air this thing
just sips power now as far as real world
usable battery life we're looking at six
hours for the XPS and 12 hours of mixed
use for the MacBook Air this thing is
super super efficient and another reason
is the XPS not only does it use a lot
more power for the CPU the graphics but
the display also takes a lot of juice
and if you would go for the cheaper
1080p LCD option well then you'll gain
about three hours of real world battery
life and you'll save quite a bit of
money but of course this display is
amazing it is so nice to have and you
get six hours compared to a long time
ago where you'd get more like three to
four with the older processors so to
answer the original question who makes
the best 15-inch MacBook or 15 inch
laptop is it the MacBook or the XPS well
it is tough because the MacBook Air is
fanless it's super thin and light and
has incredible battery life while still
having really good performance but the
XPS really surprised me it is more
expensive and of course you can cut down
on the ssds the ram you can save some
money there but it is such a nice
machine the speakers blew me away the
display is incredible the performance on
on battery power is way better than in
previous generations and overall I would
have to give the win to the Dell XPS if
you want the best 15-inch laptop I would
say it is the XPS as long as you don't
need Mac OS and a lot of people need
Windows so Della's done a fantastic job
on this machine but if you're looking
for the battery life and the thinness
then the MacBook definitely does a
killer job and it is less expensive as
well you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below click
that Circle above to subscribe this been
Max and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
thank you